welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Tarek Thatcher an assistant professor
of political science and a research
fellow at the Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale
University professor Thatcher's research
focuses on political parties and party
voter linkages social movements ethnic
politics and South Asian politics his
work has appeared in comparative
politics and contemporary South Asia
today we'll talk with him about his
recent paper entitled embedded
mobilization non-state service provision
as electoral strategy in India in it he
looks at how religious nationalists in
India use social services to expand to
their electoral base among the poor
welcome professor that show thank you
for having me let's begin with an
overview of your paper and some of the
questions you address in it sure but
most broadly I guess the paper was
really interested in trying to examine
how we get unlikely situations of voting
and mostly how do parties at the rich
ever appeal to poor voters and in fact
in low-income and democracies like India
all parties regardless of who their
primary basis has to make at least some
inroads among the poor in order to be
successful and so what I got interested
in is how does the party that's
understood as the party of the elite in
India which is the Hindu nationalist
party agenda Party or BJP how do they
actually really try to make inroads
among lower caste voters and essentially
this was a way for me to look at two
questions first
how do rich parties attract poor voters
and secondly how do religious
nationalists attract those who are
considered far removed from their
ideology because the second thing about
Hindu nationalism was that it was
historically understood as an upper
caste phenomenon it was something that
was popular among upper caste Hindoo
elites and it was in fact lower castes
were understood to always be far removed
from what the movement preached about
what Hinduism was what it took to be a
good Hindu
and for those reasons I was interested
in seeing how did this party go about
the difficult task of appealing to these
voters for whom we could offer little in
terms of its economic policies which
largely favored the rich in terms of its
ideology which largely favored upper
castes so given that situation what
could they in fact do and the basic
argument that I make in the paper which
is taken from my dissertation was that
it wasn't anything that the political
party did but instead work that it's
part that its partners in the wider
social movement of Hindu nationalism did
which was to provide basic social
services so very basic schooling very
basic medical care the type that's
common among other religious movements
worldwide
it was those services that really
created the breakthrough for Hindu
nationalists in parts of India and so
the paper that that you referenced was
looking at how that process actually
took place and how did you come to write
the paper what about this topic
interests you how did you get drawn to
it well I actually didn't think about
writing it when I went to graduate
school but what interested me was that
the 2004 national elections in India
took place early on while I was in
graduate school and the results in that
results it was the Hindu nationalist
party that actually lost the election
and so I was reading headlines about the
elections that were trying to make sense
of why they had lost because most
pundits had expected them to win and the
consensus was there was actually the
poor who had voted them out of office
the party had run on a platform called
India shining which was meant to
showcase India's achievement and arrival
on the world stage and while that was
seen to play well with middle-class
urban voters it was seen to kind of
denigrate the the experiences of the
poor who had been continuing to suffer
even through India's economic boom so
pundits said this was the poor voting
out the rich but when I was looking at
some of the survey data that came out of
that election that didn't seem to be the
case and there were several states in
which Hindu nationalists actually the
lead vote getter among these lower
castes and that just didn't fit with
what experts in conventional wisdom
understood to be their appeal this was
always understood as an urban middle
class upper caste party so how are they
winning these voters and so trying to
explain that that's what got me
interested
just a puzzle a very local puzzle based
on these election results and it turned
into something bigger and more
substantial so let's talk about your
methodology how did you do your research
it was a little bit tricky because of
the the research topic so it took
several steps I mean the first thing
that I was looking at was basically
trying to understand how and where these
service organizations or organizations
are actually strong and so that involved
getting a lot of data looking at you
know where these chapters actually built
in which states in India which districts
in India are they the strongest and are
those also the states and districts in
which the party is doing well with these
voters and so that was the kind of first
national level look based on those
results based on finding out which areas
of the country were these organizations
in and where was the party doing well I
selected some cases for more in-depth
analysis and so basically what I did was
I looked at one case the case the papers
based on where they succeeded where
these service organizations were present
and they clearly seemed to be
corresponding to higher votes for the
Hindu nationalists but I also looked at
a couple of cases where they've tried
these service organizations were there
but there weren't the resulting
electoral gains that we would expect for
the party arm because I wanted to see
where the situations in which it seems
to work and where does it not work and
then within each of these states I did a
mixture of my own surveys to see whether
where the service organizations were
whether the individuals that they were
getting and benefiting were the ones who
were actually turning their votes for
the BJP for the Hindu nationalists and I
also did a lot of interviews with the
providers you know trying to track how
they went about their service provision
how did they actually get people who
didn't trust them lower caste people who
were untrusting of upper caste activists
to actually even come to their schools
even accept the benefits that they were
offering and also talked to ordinary
voters to say you know what do they make
of these services what did they make of
the party based on these services and
things like that there's a lot of
difference okay and who are the
providers and and what are the services
that you're talking about some example
sure so the providers are mostly
activists with the Hindu nationalist
movement and in the first generation
these tend to be upper caste urban men
who often leave their families located
in cities and travel into areas where
lower castes and tribals Indian Indian
tribal populations live which are often
very far away from their home and so
this obviously involves a lot of
sacrifice and is due only to their very
intense ideological commitment to the
movement and so they tend to be young
and often have very long stints of 10 15
20 years sometimes their family will
later come out and join them sometimes
they don't have families their wedded
only to the movement so that's who they
are and I spend a lot of time with these
guys trying to figure out why they did
this with the decided to do this and how
successful what kind of obstacles they
faced was it hard to find these
individuals that's I mean that's pretty
that's an amazing um its thing it's it's
it's hard initially but these networks
are very tight and they're very tightly
controlled to the central movement so if
you can make inroads which I did while I
was doing some initial fieldwork in the
capital a lot of this is through words
of mouth it's it's getting cell phone
numbers or getting addresses and showing
up and waiting and often you get turned
away initially but over time that's
often what took the longest time was
just making that first step but once you
do and you're accepted and they and they
trust you they're a very tightly
networked very organized group and so
you can very quickly meet many more
people within the network the services
that they offer are actually very basic
we're not talking about you know big
school buildings and fancy hospitals
most of the time we're talking about a
single activist located in a village who
will run a school a one teacher school
but there's not even off in a physical
building so he will just take mostly he
sometimes she will just take a space any
open space in the village a room in a
house if somebody is willing to donate
that and teach class and that for three
to four hours a day sometimes longer the
hospice care is likewise the very same
they get they go to a central dispensary
run by the organization once a month get
very basic medical supplies and are
distributing them but this is in the
context of Indian villages where you
know the number one killers are highly
preventable whether it's de century or
or malaria and so even you know giving
out queen een or just mixing simple
sugar solutions for them can have a big
effect so it's very basic services but
they're still quite in demand and the
places that we're talking about
okay so correct me if I'm wrong
basically you have these men going out
into the country where the lower caste
people are living and they're providing
these services and are they trying to
talk to them about politics and you know
here I mean how does that work exactly
good question so one of the things I was
trying to uncover was you know if it
wins votes is it just that these voters
are extremely grateful for what they're
getting and they identify these
activists with the party automatically
and so start voting for the party or is
there something more that has to be done
and typically there's something more
that has to be done so there is great
material appreciation but precisely
because the party is not liked by most
of these voters when they first go into
villages they make no mention of
politics they don't even mention very
much their ideology which they deeply
believe in and the reason is that you
know prior experiences where they did
that they actually got kicked out at
these villages because they were asking
people to change their religious
practice or change their eating habits
etc and so this time they went in and
they just said we're service providers
just come and take services that's all
we wanted to but over time they started
doing things that definitely helped the
party so they used to recruit their
students for example to become workers
for the party and once these students
have been with them for a long time they
develop loyalties are willing to do
things like that but they even sometimes
go around the village and try and spread
political opinion but they do this very
discretely so one of the things that
they do is they spread rumors against
opposition candidates so they don't go
out and campaign for the BJP they don't
ever want to do that but they do go and
say you know I heard that this person
has actually smuggled some money in the
previous election or I heard this person
faked his certificate certifying that he
was qualified to run this election
things like that and you know because
they removed from party politics because
they're not a politician saying it their
teacher often very respected within the
village that actually carries a lot of
weight and it's a difficult thing to
measure but ended up being a very
important part of the story yeah it's
it's very interesting to me because I
would think that the people you know
I'll call it a village would catch on to
the fact that this purse
is really affiliated with this political
party so that's why we're very
interesting phenomenon no I think so too
and this is something I'm wrestling with
the first thing to note is that this is
a relatively recent strategy so it's
only in the last two decades that these
service chapters have really been built
up and it's really only in the last five
or ten years that we're seeing the
switches to this party so that's one or
two election cycles the question of
whether this can be sustained over time
whether they can retain this neutral
status while constantly lobbying for one
side I think remains to be seen I think
it's one of the great weaknesses of
social services as an electoral strategy
I will say that I don't think it's that
voters are being blindly fooled I think
it's more that they begin to respect
these people and therefore respect their
opinions and think that maybe the party
is worth a shot right now the flip side
of that is if the party keeps coming to
power and then implementing policies
that continue to only help the rich that
could be another source so whether this
is sustainable strategy I don't know
it's done some remarkable things in
parts of India and creating coalition's
we never thought we were gonna see in
Indian politics but how long those
coalition's could last is another story
okay so it's it's become a strategy to
implement you know these people to go
out into the field and then to your
point of them swaying the vote and then
implementing policies do you see is
there any research or have you seen
anything in terms of you know once the
party gets is elected and is in office
are they then going to try and implement
policy that will help the people
everyone who voted for them yeah are
things changing in that direction
because that would be obviously a
wonderful thing right I mean I think
that the the quick answer to your
question is no and this is one of the
things that I try and figure out in the
paper is what makes Social Services
attractive as a strategy and one of the
things I argue is that social services
are kind of a compensation but it's on
the cheap so the party isn't actually
implementing sale and reform or you know
vastly pro-poor policies but they're
still doing something through these
social service arms but they can really
concentrate their attentions on the rich
and the social service arms are doing
this
very basic stuff for the poor so it's
this nice way of you know making a
coalition between rich and poor but the
party has been really unwilling to do
things like one of the big things in
Indian politics is what is the caste
community that your candidates are from
and one of the big things that a lot of
new parties that represent the poor and
India are doing is they're giving more
representation to people from lower
castes you would think that if they were
gonna the Hindu nationalists were gonna
change their opinion they would start
visibly increasing the representation of
lower caste within their own ranks but
they've been reluctant to do that and I
think that's another potential thing
that you know it remains to be seen how
long they're able to keep this up one of
the things that they've helped as that's
helped them is that the states in which
they've been successful their opposition
isn't doing that much for the poor
either and so you always have to look at
what is the comparison that's being made
by voters in whom they're selecting and
so my punch would be that this is gonna
continue to be successful where the main
opposition is gonna be somebody who's
not offering that much anyway I say
let's talk about particular surprises or
any kind of difficulties you had and
doing the research well I think you
touched on the the biggest surprise for
me which is how open people were
particularly the activists in talking to
me and they weren't open in the
beginning but this is a movement that's
known for being quite tightly organized
and not very open quite reticent about
sharing their opinions but I found that
the further actually went away from
Delhi and most of my research was in
fairly remote places people were much
more open with me quite happy to talk
quite flattered that somebody was
interested in their work enough to come
out there to talk with them and so I
think the biggest surprise with me was
how warm they were and these are people
whose ideology I don't necessarily have
a great deal of sympathy for but over
time you develop personal bonds people
who look out for you share to take time
out of their day for you do much more
than that to make sure you can get to
religious or or whatever it is I think
that was one of the biggest surprises
both finding access but also what it did
to me in my own personal relationships
with these individuals in terms of
logistical different difficulties um
mostly it was just getting to these
villages I mean these are not easy
places to get to and most of the paper
that you were that you were referencing
the villages that I had to visit either
for survey work or interview work um
to take a day or two a couple of times
it rained on us and and literally the
road was washed away so I was stranded
in the village for a couple of days so
things like that were made the research
tough but but overall yeah those are the
things that stuck out and what what
conclusions do you reach in the paper um
I think the main conclusion one of the
things is that this idea of what can sue
we think of social services as an
electoral strategy right how how can we
think of these kinds of service
provision which is you know there's been
a lot written about about such service
provision by movements in the Middle
East Hamas Hezbollah movements in
Southeast Asia party movements in
Southeast Asia often affiliated with
religious movement and I think one of
the things that I'm trying to argue is
that we can't just look at it as an
exchange of goods for votes it's
something more than that these one of
the things that makes it successful is
that it's being implemented regardless
of whether it wins votes or not for long
periods of time and eventually is able
to win votes over for for the party and
it's precisely because there's Adi
linking of the political actors and the
service providers that's making it so
successful and so I think that's one of
the points I want to make and the second
is that there's a real affinity for
service to be a strategy for parties of
the rich and that in a lot of low-income
democracies there are these parties that
are increasingly realizing that poor
voters are going to need to be
independently reached out to and so
it'll be interesting to see if other
parties you know in many of the cases in
the Middle East these are not
democracies but as we're seeing some of
these areas are going democratic it'll
be interesting to see if service social
services emerge as an electoral strategy
in those countries as well so are you
gonna be following this and doing more
work on this yes very much so I'm very
interested in in kind of broadening the
scope of of this this argument outside
of India I'm currently in the process of
working on that so it's gonna be I'm
watching with great interest like
everybody else for other reasons what's
happening in the Middle East for me
there's a personal investment in this as
well so yeah I look forward to doing
that great thank you so much for being
here today and sharing some of your work
all right thank you very much for more
information about Professor Thatcher
and his work please visit our website at
Yale edu backslash Macmillan Report
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney
and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale